AND SO IN THAT WAY, DESPITE THE
TAPE MIXUP, IT REALLY COULD HAVE
THE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME THING.
WE ARE JOINED BY AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST MARK STEYN WHO IS
WATCHING FROM THE VERY FIRST GAL
HAMMER.
YOU ARE ONE OF WHO I SAY IS ONE
OF AMERICA’S GREAT EXPERTS ON
THIS TRIAL GREEDILY CONSUMED
EVERY MOMENT OF IT.
WHAT’S THE ASSESSMENT SO FAR.
>> IT’S A COMPLETE SPHINCTER
NEW SAW THE PROBLEM WITH IT
WITH DERSHOWITZ ON THE VIEW.
A CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYER
SHOULDN’T HAVE TO PUT HIMSELF IN
THAT SITUATION AND THE PROBLEM
HERE IS LAWYERLY ARGUMENTS.
THERE IS NO POINT MAKING LARGELY
ARGUMENTS, THIS IS A COMPLETELY
POLITICAL PROCESS.
PEOPLE SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
TROUBLE WITH LAWYERLY ARGUMENTS
IS IF IT’S POLITICAL, THE
PRESIDENT CAN’T BE DOING THIS,
EVEN IF YOU ACCEPT EVERYTHING
THAT JOHN BOLTON SAYS, THAT’S A
COMPLETE WASTE OF TIME.
I THINK HE SHOULD’VE ACTUALLY
DEFENDED HIMSELF.
MY PROBLEM WITH THIS BOARD OF AN
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL, THE RATINGS
ARE SO LOW, ADAM SCHIFF MAY
ATTEMPT WITH THAT SKIFF ON
SUBBASEMENT LEVEL THREE.
THERE IS NOBODY WATCHING THIS.
IT’S NOT ENOUGH OF A CIRCUS AND
TRUMP SHOULD’VE DEFENDED HIMSELF
AND SHOVE THIS THING DOWN ADAM
SCHIFF’S THROAT DIRECTLY.
THE WHOLE PROCESS IS STUPID.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE READING OUT
THE HANDWRITTEN CARDS BY PATRICK
LEAHY WHICH IN FACT IS WRITTEN
FOR HIM BY SOME NO-NAME STAFFER
IN HIS OFFICE, YOU HAVE THE
CHIEF JUSTICE LIKE SOME GAME
SHOW HOST, WHAT’S THE NEXT
QUESTION, JOHN -- THE WHOLE
THING IS RIDICULOUS!
TRUMP SHOULD’VE REVISITED
HIMSELF AND TURNED IT INTO A
REAL CIRCUS.
>> Tucker: THAT SUCH AN
INTERESTING POINT.
AS I WATCH THIS, I KEEP
THINKING, I WONDER IF THE
REPUBLICANS ARE BEING TOO
LITERAL AND THAT’S THE REASON WE
WENT FULL GAGA ON THE OPENING
TONIGHT BECAUSE IT’S HARD TO
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND IT’S HIM
AND TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
THE CHARGES DON’T EVEN MAKE
SENSE.
THE WHOLE THING IS SO NUTS!
MAYBE IT’S BETTER TO SAY THAT
OUT LOUD!
>> I WOULD’VE SAID, AS WE SAY IN
ENGLISH COURTS, SCHIFF SHOULD’VE
MADE HIS CASE AND THE DEMOCRATS
MAKE THEIR CASE, AND THE DEFENSE
SHOULD’VE JUST STOOD UP AND SAY,
AS THEY SAY IN ENGLISH COURTS,
NO CASE TO ANSWER.
AND LEFT IT BACK.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD IS
THAT THE ONLY REAL CRIME HERE,
TO GO BACK TO WHAT YOU WERE
SAYING ABOUT UKRAINE, UKRAINE IS
OUR GREATEST EVER ALLY, UKRAINE
WAS THERE WHEN WE STORMED THE
BEACHES OF NORMANDY, UKRAINIANS
VOLUNTEERS WERE AT FORT SUMTER,
THEY’VE BEEN WITH US THROUGHOUT
THE HISTORY OF THE REPUBLIC IT.
THE ONLY CRIME IN THIS THING WAS
HUNTER BIDEN WHO STOLE THE
WEALTH OF UKRAINE FROM THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE.
HUNTER BIDEN’S RACKET IS NOT
ACTUALLY A VICTIMLESS CRIME AND
THE VICTIM WAS UKRAINE.
>> Tucker: THAT SUCH A GREAT
POINT.
IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE UKRAINE IS
OUR ESSENTIAL ALLY IMPORTANT
ENOUGH TO SEND YOUR SON TO GO
DIE THERE WHICH IS THE CASE ADAM
SCHIFF HAS MADE THE CASE, YOU’D
BE UPSET THAT HUNTER BIDEN WAS T
>> THEY WANT TO BUILD A UKRAINE
SAFE ENOUGH FOR THE SONS OF
LIFETIME -- LOOK, THIS WHOLE
THING IS A JOKE!
THIS WHOLE IDEA, I DO NOT LIKE
THE IDEA OF THE LAWYERS
APPEARING TO RESIST.
THEY SHOULD SAY, JOHN BOLTON,
BRING HIM ON!
LET’S HAVE HIM IN THE WITNESS
STAND FOR TWO WEEKS.
THIS THING IS GOING SO GREAT FOR
YOU.
LET’S HAVE THEM HERE AND ASK ALL
THE QUESTIONS YOU WANT, WE HAVE
NOTHING TO FEAR.
THIS
LET’S EXTEND THIS TO
NOVEMBER 3RD, 4TH, 5TH, SEE HOW
IT WORKS OUT, YOU LOSERS.
>> Tucker: LITERALLY COULD
NOT AGREE MORE.
THAT’S THE BEST CASE AGAINST
IMPEACHMENT I’VE HEARD SO FAR.